so today's topic in cells an involuntary
celibate is someone who tries but cannot
according to themselves be successful in
meeting with other people so they
believe me on the other if you could
summarize your opinion towards women
like what I think of them yes
I do think they are very important but
hey I'm brandy I also go by Derrick hi
I'm an in cell and I'm here to answer
people's questions about the topic hi
how are you hi I'm good
so you're an info yes why would you ever
sign up to do this I I suppose I would
want to give more of a positive light on
this community which is a very negative
light upon it okay and do you think
that's a good thing yes
what why are you mad bro weird question
you think it's a good thing that you're
trying to make your people look good
okay there's a lot of boys in this
community aren't bad people but you
acknowledge that a good handful of them
are right not a good handful I'd say
small handful
that's the worst logic in canoes if
you're gonna use that logic to describe
themselves because some of them do
something terrible we could apply that
to almost any group whether it be
Muslims whether it be white people
whether it be you know like careful
careful what kind of lot school patterns
you're trying to go down because once
it's used against you you can't be like
oh that's bigoted no no you said the
same thing if a woman was elected as a
president of United States how would you
react
oh I don't know it probably would depend
on the on the woman I I probably
probably wouldn't be supportive about
honestly but why do you say that if you
don't mind me asking I do think that you
know men should be the leaders and women
should be the caregivers and the pro you
know the loving supporting the teachers
so in some cases since women of color or
just women in general have been
oppressed by certain systems and other
oppressed communities especially the
lgbtq+ all those those are don't really
fit with the spectrum that in cells or
you have been talking about so why do
you think your method of thought would
help fix what we have today he doesn't
want to fix it that's the thing like the
way you ask your question you brought
all this thing up he doesn't want to fix
that that's what he believes in do you
don't care about you you don't care
about what you've been suffering about
should be like that and that's the way
it is so you bring that to make them
feel some type of ways not like it's
gonna fail what makes you think he wants
to change that how is the way you think
gonna change that I don't want to change
anything you don't I probably wouldn't
view the things that you might view as
oppression as a matter how you think I
have a feeling I would have you add more
as how we treat children that we love
because she's approaching the
conversation as if they're both equals
he's like no no you're a child child and
you know we're gonna take care of you
like yourself we control them but we
control them lovingly not as if not as
we're forcing them to do things against
their will I would view it more as a a
loving domestic thing in the past rough
you can't say we're not treating you
like this or like this or like that and
then talk about them as if they are pets
as if they are people who are not
capable of making decisions for
themselves you are pushing them into
servitude if you're taking away their
ability to choose you're forcing them
it's like saying bro you got multiple
avenues to choose but you can't use a or
B you just got C you're not letting me
choose you're forcing me down the path
it's a fake choice exactly on this
channel we preach a lot about
accountability you know so sometimes we
have critiques of women or black y'all
can do better in this area
because you guys have the power to you
have the ability to make those decisions
for yourself and to be better so that
we're all better same thing for the men
you know when we give certain advices in
regards to certain problems in
situations and now his mantra is like no
no men should make all the choices
because ladies you don't have the moral
responsibility or the aptitude to do it
I with that so I would say that's if we
were to do it in a civilized way maybe
in a more even a Christian way even
though I'm not really advocating for a
certain religion or ideology I would
assume that women would probably be
happier and I wouldn't just assume that
blindly I would assume that based on the
data that I have seen this man is very
good not saying yes you talk a lot but
you don't say much and you talk a lot in
circles and in order to appear
diplomatic you're masking his views and
more simple languages but most of us can
still detect it just say what you want
to say yeah because your your
sugarcoating it and no one's buying it
and I think that in an attempt to make n
cells look better you've actually
managed to make them look horse what
data have you seen that has brought you
to this conclusion because I'm now
curious where I can get this data from I
couldn't reference it offhand but I
believe there was a study that I can't
remember the name of it off the top of
my head because you're talking who knows
he may not he like I've read studies
that I'll remember the nail and if you
asked me on the spot I probably wouldn't
be able to name them would you
I just think it's interesting that
Jubilee left that part in but when the
other discussion happened about studies
and stats they actually told the people
they're present do not reference your
stats do not reference your numbers
because for the sake of the discussion
we have to talk about ideas just an
interesting note because I remember I
talked to Kurtz that privately and he
said yeah they actually stopped me from
speaking about the studies I'm
referencing because they didn't like us
talking based off facts one-sided so
just an interesting like editing note
but let's keep going okay what do you
think it is about liberal areas that
create behavior and women that you think
is a problem promiscuity leads to
increased standards in
more primitive aspects such as looks and
that typically makes it harder for some
people to find a relationship including
sometimes good-looking people I there's
guys who are much better looking than I
am who are having a really hard time
finding someone in a place like LA or in
London or in Auckland New Zealand but
they probably would have a perfectly
fine time finding a woman somewhere else
so you think that perm eschewing is the
problem and if people were more
monogamous and more withholding that
would sort of fix society yeah I suppose
people were more traditionalist so by
people not being monogamous and B not
being promiscuous you think it's gonna
give you more chances of scoring the
mathematics of that is broken how so if
more people are monogamous
then that doesn't mean that he'd have
more chance of scoring how cuz let's say
if there's 50 women and fifty men and
each one of them can only couple with
one person that more people are gonna
couple there's some people they're gonna
couple with nobody if people are more
monogamous if they're if they're more
promiscuous and they're going around
they're gonna be like a man whatever no
no cuz it imagine let's say it's like
the job market you want to apply to high
level job they're not hiring you you're
gonna accept a lower paying top the same
idea with dating people settle all the
time yeah so I did it a day it is
certainly true that in more monogamous
societies where monogamy is far more
encouraged through culture that more
people couple with each other but if
you're more promiscuous and you have 50
people or 50 people you're gonna go
around no it's literally ten guys that's
literally the definition of a hypergamy
which is how women operate they go out
there look for a buff so the guys who
are below their level are not getting
something but the guys are ten guys are
forty guys aren't and it's like that
even on college campuses college
campuses if you look there's actually a
small minority of men who plough all the
women's wear these actually stated that
they were in sales or what do you think
about their actions I condemn their
actions I do think that the reason why
they committed those actions was
probably because of out of desperation
or out of
you know mental problems it probably
could have been prevented had the the
white support was in their in their
community in their household if they
have you know if people you know saw
what they were posting and saw what they
were experiencing in life and did
something to help them I agree even in
the point of insults I'll give you that
whenever CV state that they're lonely
and stuff like that it might be very my
lad or the best way that they could
express themselves
sure so but so and they're gonna be
ostracized for that just the fact that
men or people that do not talk about the
mental issues because of the pressure of
the society in other other things or
whatnot one of the common criticisms
about the insult community is that you
feel entitled to intimacy do you believe
that you deserve um I think everybody at
some level deserves someone that they
someone that loves them and you know
respects them as long as you are also
consistently you've disrespected women
you say everybody deserves someone
that's gonna love them and respect them
but you're not respecting women because
you keep in mind you want to treat him
like children how is that gonna make you
labor uh well he would argue that even
if he did respect to him and he still
wouldn't get laid I understand that but
it takes wouldn't just respect it's more
than RESP CTE understand this life is
not a song I mean I've been rejected and
rejected rejected and at some point you
have to understand if you do the same
thing and expect a different result
that's just a definition of insanity and
seven I think there's someone here in
Canada and mature as a matter of fact
that is giving classes to new immigrants
just to tell them how things work with
women here because women here don't have
the same way of thinking that in their
countries you know people might be
awkward and for some way because they
act in a certain way you know if you
hate him from Haiti and you just came to
my job and you came with all your hatred
Swagger it might not work here you're
gonna be trying to speak a French
Bonjour my my sad
c'mon honey boo boo Sonic corn here yes
though nothing I love countered by
saying his argument would probably be
that's a matter of changing your culture
what he can't change our looks and his
looks are always getting excluded from
the dating pool it's not just about
looks jay-z is wit Beyonce but let's
remember that but he's also gonna
counter then by saying yeah it's about
social status he'll say it's about
making mad money I know some jay-z's
that are not jay-z you understand what
I'm saying and they're getting it
minimum wage jay-z's yeah money or fame
or all of that you have certain assets
listen this very dude right by now
people are like oh his guys disgusting
but he's not a bad-looking dude he could
get some with this attitude it's like
one attitude leads to another thing
which is another thing he's stuck in a
loop that's not gonna get him something
if you can't tell the world about
something about being insult that you
know um that may not be in the internet
or that's overlooked heavily well would
it be I don't know I think it's mostly
that most of the men are not inherently
bad people a lot of them are just lonely
they just need some help really okay
would you say that there's anything that
other people can do to help guide or
just support or you know the lonely
person in your class or the lonely
person in your workplace maybe maybe
he's an in cell and he's not letting you
know and he's just kind of afraid to you
want someone positive just just be nice
say hi
trying to make friends with him you
don't have to date him you don't have to
in the Jubilee video didn't you say you
couldn't be friends with a woman that
woman can be your best friend you know
like what so so oh maybe you got
receipts yeah you did say that yeah oh
yeah okay okay maybe Derek's credit what
he was trying to say he's like just be
friendly to the person and show them
that they're not ignored by society
completely maybe I'm gonna say baby just
use his words wrong because Derek
doesn't strike me as the kind of person
who knows how to communicate effectively
or uses terms properly
hence the fact why we probably shouldn't
let men like him make decisions for
themselves
oh and that we should and we should
babysit them I see what you did there
you don't know why not yeah you have to
be pretty dumb to make Derek look smart
it's literally like I wanna be an
involuntary celibate do you have to
fight fighters yeah why cuz I'm a
firefighter you don't have to see the
bad things in the world and then come
out a bad person you can just see the
bad things in the world and then improve
upon yourself because of them I suppose
so you do have hope yeah III have hope
yeah I'm a very hopeful person I suppose
thank God I don't think he's gonna being
in so much longer I think he's gonna
figure it out he's not nearly as dumb or
as bad as make people have made him out
to be I do think he has some logical
inconsistencies and he's betting some
bad thinking patterns but at the end of
the day if you were constantly
encountering failure in life you cannot
go at it with the mindset that the world
is the problem because that's a losing
attitude it takes the agency away from
you it takes the power away from you and
you tell yourself I am in this situation
because the world is like this no you're
in the situation because of a lot of the
choices that you make and your poor
strategies I do think the insult
community gets a bit of a bad rap and
some of it is self-imposed just because
the way they talk about women in private
and all this stuff that comes to light
not so involuntary a lot of what the
face is self is something for sure sure
100% understand but I do think that
there has been a lot of
mischaracterizations I think people not
taking the time to see it as a mental
health problem you know loneliness is an
epidemic in North America in general and
most of the Western developed world
people are dealing with net loneliness
in terrible ways and you know what the
insult community is equivalent of like
the female equivalent would be
k.michelle all men are noble you need to
find out about what it is about your
patterns that makes it a hundred or why
do you keep attracting those thin people
yeah yeah Kate Michelle is this dark
female in cells they're called stem
cells you see that
the opposite end when women become very
lonely and become very they also engage
in bad forms of self-preservation what
these men are doing is another form of
that I don't encourage it it doesn't do
good for your mental health we have a
loneliness problem in the society and
the best thing that we can do is to
address that address that issue now some
of their strategies that they're
suggesting is essentially that like you
know forced monogamy I don't think
that's a tenable situation
okay I really I don't think it's a
terrible situation but why do you think
it's a bad idea first doesn't solve the
problem the prop the person is still
gonna have those patterns you're gonna
force people to get into what someone
else it doesn't solve the issue it just
solved one symptom and the symptom is
you not being with someone you are a
certain way mentally and you have those
patterns mentally therefore it prevents
you from being with someone now you're
just fixing the being with someone part
but this thing over here is not changed
therefore when eventually this thing
breaks the pattern is gonna repeat
itself it's just like whenever you're
sick if I have a headache and I just
take an aspirin to have a headache well
I'm just solving that but what is the
actual problem do I have high blood
pressure do I have and that's what you
have to solve the problem when I if I
keep on eating crap I'm gonna keep on
having the headaches right isn't it
possible that they're saying that if I
do find that person that a lot of that
stuff over here is no longer gonna be a
thing patterns are gonna stay the same
what's gonna happen is that if ever
you're with to break up with that person
you're only gonna fall deeper in your
patterns because it's gonna be a
deception and your patterns are not
gonna be solved so no I believe you need
to solve the problems and then after
that get with the person and I see one
is gonna lead to the other
that's what I think but I'm no expert I
see women who constantly complain about
the dating scene he's really gonna be
unhappy unhappy the reason why they're
gonna be unhappy because they weren't
there before right it's okay so I think
we have to have a society where people
are able to choose that has to be the
case even if even if you don't want to
get an engagement in casual in terms
you should have the right to do so if
you want to that's what I believe that
being said I do think the way a lot of
dating trends are going right now a lot
of people just seem displeased with the
scene so maybe there is some validity to
the idea that we may want to encourage
monogamy a bit more now no matter what
the grass is always gonna be greener and
people are gonna have complaints yo a
bird millionaires complain ah the
weather you could go anywhere you want
but I would argue that if people are
rating their levels of happiness way
higher in countries where monogamy is
far more encouraged maybe there is a
point to the idea that the way we're
doing things isn't healthy for us we do
have an epidemic of loneliness in our
countries we do find people who have no
one in their lives and it is a problem
because we do know that if you are
single in your old age especially you're
a higher blood race of dying soon mmm
the high rates of all kinds of other
issues right so I think there's a lot of
things that come to that it would be
unfair to be like oh because it's a
place where we don't encourage monogamy
that they are there's a higher place of
loneliness that it's a relation no well
now there's more factors in that just
the internet use in the way that people
are really on their phones is also so
there's more than one I believe they're
shorter one factor it's very rarely
anything is it's just putting it on that
I'm just saying that would be just I
don't think anyone's making the argument
they're putting it just on that you
should always find for all the variables
that contribute to a problem yeah that
being said yeah if we do have an
epidemic and we do find that people are
not in relationships people are never
dating people are never having those
opportunities a lot of people this is
not a small it's a lot of people maybe
the way that we're structuring society
is not working it's like it's like
extreme forms of capitalism yeah we're
always like Apple is great but then when
you see like the wealthiest of the way
it's not good and you know what happens
when there's too much inequality right
worth it becomes a problem for all
society yeah and so if we have that in
the dating world as well I could see how
that could become a problem now cuz you
go through but I mean this is us just
talking through some ideas I think I
disagree with with it was in sauce and
their stances I I sympathize because I
think loneliness is a
problem we do should we do treat it like
a mental health issues so that should be
accorded to them because I just think
those are lonely people who have found
people who feel that way and at the end
I did we want to be understood and we
want people to get us and so I
understand why that community exists but
I do think it's it's bad to be around
people who are in the same project drug
addicts hanging out with drug addicts
it's not a good idea
right and so in that same token I think
this is also similar anything when in
South as well that what I've seen any
having come in if they have poor social
skills yeah how do you teach people
social skills do you think what I'm
saying often the lack of social skills
comes with having anxiety and sublet and
there's much more anxiety there's so
much to untangle there's so much so many
other factors that you know that we have
to test and I think we've covered a lot
of them whether it be the mental health
problems and income monogamy yes it's a
lot we get that I just think the the
stigma associated with being in sell and
the way people talk about all the time
isn't conducive to them coming forward
and talking about their mental health
issues if you already feel shame and you
already feel invalid because the way
society treats you then society looking
at you for being an insult and then
telling you you're trash some more does
it make you want to seek help it just
drives you towards darker places there
so I think being more open about these
things the same way when we talked about
k.michelle we said yo heal that trauma
because it's not gonna help people we
have to have that same conversation with
people who are insults even if their
views are terrible you have to
understand those views are generally a
byproduct of the battle of centering so
if we undo those loops I feel like a lot
of those views will also be undone
mm-hmm so that's where I stand on this
um I think it's always an interesting
discussion to have and we're glad to
have it with you guys so let us know
what you think in the comments below
about in cells and what we've talked
about some of our ideas today
[Music]